(gentle uplifting music)
Here's a little weekday motivation
from someone who inspires us.
Hey Drew, it's Arianne Phillips.
I'm a costume designer here in Hollywood.
You might know my work from movies like,
Girl Interrupted or Walk the Line,
Kingsman the Secret Service,
or Once Upon A Time In Hollywood.
Looking back, I would've never ever thought
that I would be a costume designer,
let alone a three time Oscar nominated costume designer.
It's really for me about following your instinct
and being curious and saying yes.
I mean, my mantra is yes.
Being able to be open to new experiences
and new opportunities.
One of the most incredible things
about being a costume designer
is being part of this incredible tribe of women.
We are nearly 85% women
within the costume designers in the film industry.
Talk about girl power,
this month during women's history month,
we are coming together as a group
to talk about pay equity because we are paid 30% less
than other creative department heads,
who are predominantly male.
The fact that we can come together
as women in the industry
and stand up and talk about the work that we do is really
something that inspires me every day.
Thank you for sharing that with us.
(bright upbeat music)